youri la parole et à monsieur paul salen
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre le président de la
république l'a réaffirmé hier l'euro
2016 aura bien lieu
cependant étant donné le contexte
sécuritaire que nous connaissons la
question quant à la sécurité dans les
stades mais aussi aux abords que ce soit
pour le public ou pour les joueurs doit
d'être posée le ministère de l'économie
s'apprêtait la semaine dernière a envoyé
un courrier à l'ensemble des acteurs
économiques pour leur rappeler de faire
preuve d'une vigilance renforcée pendant
cette période
par ailleurs selon porte parole du
syndicat national des entreprises de
sécurité
il risque d'y avoir des problèmes
d'effectif du côté des prestataires de
sécurité privée en parallèle se pose la
question de sécurité des fanzone espaces
dans lesquels les matchs seront diffusés
au corps des villes et qui accueille
ronde dit mme pilar 5000 personnes des
mesures de sécurité ont été confirmés
pas le patient systématiques à l'entrée
par des agents de sécurité privés
interdiction d'objets volumineux
détection éventuelle d'objets
métalliques intervention de services de
déminage et installation de l'important
dispositif de vidéosurveillance
chez le premier ministre toutes ces
mesures ont un coût financier important
pouvez vous nous dire comment seront
répartis et financé au niveau de l'état
et aussi des villes qui accueilleront
cet euro en effet dans certaines d'entre
elles
l'équipement de moyens de surveillance
demandée aux abords des stades et des
fanzone entraînera en retard pour eux
pour d'autres équipements qu'ils avaient
prévu par ailleurs d'autres dispositifs
de sécurité sont ils prévus en dehors
des villes accueillant les matches et
les fans zone enfin des vous envisagé
dans le cas où certaines rencontres
pourrait créer de nombreuses tensions ou
faire l'objet de menaces plus libre et
que les matchs puissent se jouer à huis
clos
tu le mets premier ministe c'est toutes
ces précisions que nous souhaitons que
vous nous apportiez sur la sécurité
autour de cet euro 2016 afin que cet
événement puisse rester uniquement un
grand moment de rassemblement sportif
merci monsieur salen la parole est à
monsieur bernard cazeneuve ministre
l'intérieur
oui monsieur le député le gouvernement
partage bien entendu chacune des
préoccupations vous avez exprimé dans
votre question il n'est pas d'ailleurs
le seul à partager ses préoccupations
puisque
alain juppé qui est le président de des
villes d'accueil de l'euro 2016 avec
lequel nous travaillons étroitement et
dans lequel j'imagine vous avez toute
confiance partage totalement cette
préoccupation avec nous que faisons nous
on semble pour essayer de faire en sorte
que l'euro 2016 se passe dans de bonnes
conditions d'abord comme vous l'avez dit
nous nous employons à sécuriser au mieux
les fans zone la sécurisation des fans
zone ça suppose une mobilisation très
forte des forces de sécurité intérieure
ça suppose un recrutement à un niveau
qui appelle la mobilisation du ministère
du travail des agents de sécurité privés
dont vous avez raison de dire qu'ils
sont très sollicités et il faut nous
assurer que nous aurons la ressource
humaine nécessaire pour assurer cette
sécurisation s'appelle aussi vous
m'interrogez sur ce point une
participation de l'état l'état
participera à hauteur de 80% des frais
de vidéo protection nécessaires pour la
sécurisation de ses fans zone et de
l'épreuve est par ailleurs pour le
financement des agents de sécurité
privés dans les fan zone de manière à ce
que les collectivités locales ne soient
pas laissés seuls face aux coûts nous
avons décidé avec alain juppé la semaine
dernière après un arbitrage du premier
ministre de nous répartir le financement
de cette opération en faisant appel aux
instances du football en faisant appel
aux financements de l'état de manière à
ce que les villes n'est qu'un
financement marginal apte et comme vous
l'avait indiqué dans les fan zone nous
prenons toutes précautions pour procéder
aux palpations de sécurité pour faire en
sorte qu' on ne puisse pas y entrer avec
des sacs et des bagages pour faire en
sorte qu'il y ait une fluidité de
l'entrée de ses fans zone pour qu'il n'y
ait pas de fil qui puisse servir de
cible et bien entendu en fonction des
éléments dont nous disposons des
services de renseignement à tous nos
moments nous adapterons notre stratégie
à la réalité du risque
merci monsieur lemay